ok
desculpe
o lado pessoal aqui quem fala é preciso
muito bem vindos na mais um vídeo e hoje
tráficos um vídeo bastante toque e se
não conseguir coisas torce questões
eu não sei o que acontece portanto vamos
estar aqui hoje já sabe o pessoal não
tem isso em casa devido às centenas de
ver aqui o vídeo eu vou estar com toda a
proteção necessário que a mentira
pessoas nós vamos tentar cozinhar porque
detergentes para a roupa e inseticida
para moscas e insetos que este que deve
ser bem tóxico mesmo que aqui embaixo
diz que matou os peixes vocês mandarem
proibiu o gel antibacteriano plasmam
destaque também extremamente improvável
vamos ver o que vai acontecer na nossa
filha de vera e comecem desde já o que
cachorro vai acontecer assim que as
coisas vão pegar fogo vai virar esse
gasto com 52 misteriosa que vamos
cozinhar primeira criança naquela coisa
péssima idéia o que parece manteiga aqui
porque ela quando falo isso aqui está
aqui eu acho que são as cápsulas
eu e voz misteriosa tivemos doente este
tempo todo que eu coloquei vídeo mas
foram três dias então nós tentamos
recuperar mas mesmo assim quase
impossível não gostar horrível
enfim vamos tentar continuar a colocar
um vídeo por dia
satisfatório eo preço ainda que dentro
bora lá então ligar o nosso furacão
[Música]
ok para potência máxima agora é só
esperar um pouco e que terá que ser
afegão incrível fuga no chip assim há
quatro dias em 14 dias
ela estava virar a nosso ver isso porque
tenho que material explosivo
já estamos protegidos contra as toxinas
e também óculos de proteção
espero que esse caso não eu vou morrer
aqui um táxi cadu não é não é um produto
também vai ter uma máscara de proteção
um misterioso
eu não quero morrer precisa de continuar
a filmar e eu preciso ainda do lado de
vocês quando é que tu queres preto rio
claro
não sei lá seguiu sem um só sangue week
neste vídeo meu filho já que o véu a voz
misteriosa se não quiser e vocês nunca
vão saber que devia ser esse que não
poderia dizer coisas que dizem vai lá só
31 vai o buraco do brasil e china muito
bem
achei um pouquinho lei este nome do teu
o assistente eu acho que é normal porque
as máquinas aqui em 90 graus
então é normal que o clássico seja
resistente
ok se aproximava fica muito intenso
chega muito bem qualquer ficou mais ou
menos assim está o resto não é assim tão
tóxico porque consegui estar aqui perto
da chegada qualquer favor ela adora
fazer o teste de inflamar tribuinal eu
vamos ver se pega fogo isso não é
inflamável
nem os cachorros tóxicos
estamos a salvo comunique de lavar roupa
olha pessoal próxima coisa que nós vamos
tentar cozinhar vai ser aqui o óbvio
anticongelante explique que serve pra
fazer um tour mas ao mesmo tempo não
congela os carros continuam lá fora e
como faz muito frio é preciso explicar e
não com gel mas o que acontecerá se nós
que seremos excluídos que acontecerá eu
pegue fogo em um pega
vamos ver
é the constant 1321 o a itália está com
um
[Música]
o efeito incrível pra fazer umas bolhas
estranhas como fez aquelas ruas na
banheira
sim eu espero fomos sim sim eu vou
tentar sentir o cheiro agora cheira
muito mal seu nome não ser bom é que
agora sim eu sinto o cheiro tóxico
equipa sempre chega tóxico
eu vou colocar mais pressão mais ele vai
ter que fazer uma personagem esta opção
aqui ela transforma todas as pessoas que
deixaram a equipe em estragar as férias
eu acho que vou morrer só não faço em
casa não acontece nada ele vai demorar
um pouquinho mas é bem resistente ao
calor só querem que eu faça um vídeo
arte está expondo aqui é constante
hoje eu comentei também o que eu posso
fazer a cozinha já passei com o cheiro
estranho está próxima coisa que nós
vamos testar considera que a nossa
cozinha da fran é jean de baterias com
álcool então ao que aconteça o que
aconteceu eu como você tenta pegar fogo
pega fogo na sala só uma festa em casa
com a escola nacional de circo ao com
321 bairro o que foi tomoko fujii deve
começar a borbulhar online
o pessoal está inflamada
obviamente que é o movimento que freei 2
sáb
a banda metallica trás concluiu
a bola sobrou para a próxima experiência
só não vou deixar aqui por último a
companhia iria até o fim e os
participantes ano e face muito tóxico eu
tenho capacidade para destruir o meio
ambiente são mataram produção matar
animais não mata só mata moscas tsé é
insano o capital da companhia até o fim
agora nós vamos estar protegendo pro
chão isso aqui é o anti bateria não cair
pra lavar o chão lava tudo estava também
com certeza usa muito isso em casa quer
vamos a isso agora 321 bairro estava de
espuma toca mal muito mal só com um
produto que chega muito bem mas quando
tem assim uma concentração porque a
nokia ea alemã a chegar muito mas muito
mal porque está muito concentrada
qualquer bastante está impossível tirar
fotos assistir o tempo cada mega os
olhos do mundo como agora
vamos ver se é formada por lá não eu
acredito estar porque as coisas quando
aquecem podem ter outro efeito então é
isso que nós temos de estar aqui em casa
mesmo assim não façam isso em casa cai
apenas assistir um vídeo de virtudes
embora lá então pro nosso último para lá
só vamos cozinhar os minutos 5 para
moscas bola só para vocês terem uma
idéia do quão inflamável isto é vamos
fazer um teste
[Música]
op está superada
o jogo
a falta de 90 jogos da paz
[Música]
qualquer só nós estamos fazendo aqui uma
brincadeira o movimento que estou
traumatizada e isso é só pra comédia mas
de qualquer forma agora falando sério
estava um cheiro muito intenso acreditar
muito forte não faça o mesmo em casa
porque isso é muito tóxico mesmo eu
tenho aqui uma marcha que eu possa
implodir e vai estrear-se a usar uma
máscara de amanhã é muito forte a ser
emo é muito forte muito forte eu nunca
pensei que vocês sintam fortes não lhe
faria uma m
[Música]
não pega um pega pouco e não pessoais
foi o vídeo de hoje espero que vocês
tenham gostado já sabem não testem casa
ok aqui vocês puderam ver como é que em
alguns produtos no frigir era eu posso
fazer uma parte 2 se vocês deixarem
realmente os 100 m like neste vídeo eu
também vou falar a voz misteriosa que
vocês tanto pedem como embaixo pessoal
daqui faz mais vídeo tóxico e eu vou
fazer meu filho tóxica que protela longa
e espero que vocês tenham gostado fique
bem aqui